تعود صفارات الانذار لتدور في العديد من
مدن ومقاطعه اوكرانيا منذره بضربات جويه
وصاروخيه روسيه وذلك بحسب المتحدثين باسم
قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
فثمت حاله ترقب تلقي بظلالها على مختلف
الجبهات لمرحله ما بعد معركه خرسان لاسيما
في ظل تصريحاتنا برئيس مجلس الامن القومي
روسي
بان بلاده لم تستخدم بعده ترسنتها الكامله
ولم تقصف كل اهداف العدو المحتمله فكل شيء
في وقته بحسب تعبيره في مقاطعه خرسان بدات
القوات الاوكرانيات تمشيط المناطق التي
انسحبت منها القوات الروسيه لازاله
الالغام والمتفجرات مؤكده حصولها على
غنائم كثيره بسبب ما وصفته بالانسحاب
الفوضوي للجيش الروسي من تلك المناطق لكن
احدث
باكات كانت من نصيب الجبهه الشرقيه لا
سيما في مقاطعه دونيت اذا يؤكد
الانفصاليون المولون لروسيا انهم يواصلون
التقدم في محور مطار دونيسك الدولي وانهم
على وشك السيطره على بلده بيرمومايسك التي
يمكن وصفها بخط الدفاع للقوات الاوكرانيه
عن المناطق التي لا تزال تحت سيطرتها شمال
غربي المقاطعه في المقابل ذكرت قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه انها صد ثمانيه
محاولات التقدم للقوات الروسيه على محاور
القتال في هذه المقاطعه بما في ذلك محور
بيرفض اما في لوجان المقاطعه الثانيه في
اقليم دون بس فقال الحاكم الاوكراني ان
جيش بلاده استعاده السيطره على 11 بلده
منذ سبتمبر الماضي وانه مازال يتقدم لكن
ببطء بسبب الالغام التي زرعتها القوات
الروسيه
[موسيقى]